this is what it's all about either you
want it to work forward thinking you
want everybody to have the ability to
say how they feel what they want to move
forward or you don't or you want
somebody who says I'm going to be on day
one I'm going to be a dictator who says
it to you tells you I'm going put you
people away I'm going to take all the
journalists I'm going take all the gay
folks I'm going to move you all around
and disappear you if that's the country
you want you know who to vote for if
that's not if that's not the country you
want you have to make a decision in aary
May it may they may like that but the I
believe the people of the United States
will make themselves very clear I see
you I see that face you guys your lips
to just because you're in the office of
the presidency you can't just imag
suddenly do whatever you want can't just
Roundup journalists and all that stuff